i'm thinking about the erosion of the
united states and what this means moving
forward and here's what freaks me out
all right we got the story here
this one
from forbes
anticipating war with china the u.s air
force is fanning out across the pacific
so
the u.s air force is concerned that
china a chinese rocket attack would wipe
out two of our most prominent air force
bases so we are dispatching all of these
different squadrons to different
airports and different islands all
across the pacific so we have rapid
response we've decentralized so they
can't just take us out
it's got this gets me worried because we
have another story here i covered this
last week june 1st pentagon eyes new
bombs for war with china not isis the
pentagon's been shifting up its strategy
no longer are we engaging in
preparations for war in the middle east
you know there's a report saying we're
like halfway out of afghanistan and now
the bombs they're buying are for pacific
warfare and not middle eastern warfare
and it could just be
we're
all done middle east is over we got
enough oil we've built enough nation
we're out and because of that well we
might as well buy bombs for pacific
because that's a bigger threat right or
it could be that we're actually gearing
up towards a war with china now here's
what freaks me out
the u.s is in is in chaos man i mean
maybe we're not maybe it's all an
illusion but come on you look at news
they're screaming at insurrection
anderson cooper claiming january 6 was
worse the worst political attack on the
us since the civil war and i'm like i
seem to recall john f kennedy getting
his head blown off but okay dude
whatever you say that's that's insanity
what happens right now if china moves in
on taiwan
and the u.s can do nothing to stop it
there it is
i mean we have to stand by there's no
way
i i don't think i would ever authorize
the arms against china to defend taiwan
not unless it was our soil or like an
ally or something i mean i mean they're
an ally they are an ally
so this is where
things get bad because if china does
move in taiwan and there's serious fear
in the us that they they are planning an
invasion i mean we see the beaching
drills there's photos of it
and uh their planes are flying over the
town went straight they're sending
strike groups through the strait of
taiwan
it's not just about taiwan it's about
china's incursions into the south china
sea it's about their military bases
their expansion their violation of
certain international conventions
so
the fear i have is the us is clearly
preparing for war
china they've been gearing up for some
time this is a more direct announcement
what this says to me is
do you think the u.s military just
decided right now
that they're worried about war with
china do you think it was just like
today they're like hey oh there might be
war with china let's move our planes or
is it more likely they got intelligence
classified about a potential war with
china made a bunch of crazy economic
moves behind the scenes
and then make the public moves everyone
can see could be china also said i think
i heard from you that china was like
threatened nuclear war if we tried to
investigate well in response to biden's
call for an investigation into covid the
head of global times said we need to
start building more nuclear bombs and to
shiver down the spine of the the
american illegal okay yeah that's i
think which is another way of saying we
are innocent
[Laughter]
and obviously the incursions the hong
kong the way they treated the yeah the
protesters in hong kong was was drastic
i think i fear i think we're in trouble
man joe biden didn't commemorate d-day
um really why not i don't know
i don't i i don't i look
here's one of the issues he finally
didn't know what day it was oh that's
for sure that's not even the choice
i was kidding because obviously people
in his administration would no one make
some kind of announcement tell him to do
it no hey or tweet for him
yeah now here's one of the problems i
don't know
every year every tweet that's ever been
sent out or every statement's ever been
made about d-day it could just be that
now we're in this deeply tribal
political realm conservatives noticed
biden didn't do this brought it up and
everyone's like hey yeah why didn't you
and it's like well i don't know maybe
jimmy carter didn't i don't know
or maybe he still should have regardless
he didn't and a lot of other people did
maybe kamala harris saying enjoy the
long weekend is also an alarming
statement maybe kamalaire's refusing
harris for fees and go to the border is
also kind of alarming and it makes me
feel like our current administration is
not invested in this country i feel like
we have an administration that
in a normal timeline
shouldn't have
have won but we aren't in a normal
timeline what i mean by this is
normally you get a strong administration
that wants to win that wants a policy
that wants to put things forward and
make these demands
well that was trump's administration man
did he want some crazy stuff a big
beautiful wall from sea to shining sea
30 feet concrete he had plans he wanted
things biden
his his whole campaign
was that he was not trump
so what happens people really didn't
like trump
a lot of things happen we'll see what
happens with this maricopa stuff joe
biden ends up uh you know getting 81
million votes he wins the election with
no plan
no one voted for anything they just
didn't want trump now we have an
administration that clearly doesn't care
so i want to say a normal timeline they
weren't proposing anything substantive
other than joe biden was hiding the
whole time
he was just like hiding in the basement
everyone's like where's by no call to
call you know he's
a lid yeah calling the lid yeah no press
so this is what you get now we're we're
we're facing the very serious prospect
of war with china our military seems to
think so
and
what can we expect in the event that war
actually breaks out my fear is that war
will come to us no matter what we do and
this is a fear that a lot of people have
in government and it leads to very
pro-war sentiment which i disagree with
but the world is not so black and white
you can't just be like i'm against war
so we therefore i will never go to war
and it's like
then you get wiped out no i mean i
understand that i'm i'm very anti-war
the number of wars that i would be
willing to support um
let's just say it's an extremely narrow
subset
that said this is a really complicated
situation i'm not gonna sit here and
automatically say there's nothing that
could ever justify that i very much do
not want to see war with china but this
is an extremely complicated situation
let's talk yeah conspiracies oh no oh
well this is also i mean obviously we
should do everything we possibly can to
avoid that war if at all possible i'm
not coming down on one side or the other
i'm being the milktoast fence that are
here but it's also because i just i
haven't um most of my interest in
foreign policy has been directed towards
the middle east because that's where the
united states has been screwing around
for the past two decades but when it
comes to china i guess i i just hadn't
really considered that it was a
realistic possibility until very
recently so you opposed war with china
what
is it you opposed war with china uh yeah
i would like not to go to war with china
but also i have no idea i mean there
could be reasons that someone brings to
my attention yeah i'm not dogmatic i
just wanted to clarify because okay so
my position is you know i don't want to
go with go to war with china but the war
may come to us that's my point so i'm
i'm a bit more in the middle than you
that means ian you have to take the
pro-war with china position i'm obsessed
i'm sweating right now dude every single
day every single day i see ian sitting
on the couch just cleaning his ar he's
like
getting ready we're getting ready you're
all laughing at me he knits he knits
wool chinese flags
and then he brings them out and he puts
them on the archery board oh my god no
i'm kidding but uh no let's talk about
uh conspiracy it's not really a
conspiracy conspiracy it's a weird word
conspiracy can i ask you something
what do you so what do you think would
have to happen um to justify a war with
china from your perspective or what do
you think would put you over the edge
where you would say like we have no
choice i don't know man
i mean usually it's like china beaching
on california and california yeah that's
kind of what i'm trying to start to
invade and there's nothing else we can
do but
yeah but it's more than that
like if if we
if we sit back
and this is this is a really tough
philosophical question and just let them
do whatever they want exactly exactly
make them get totally
stronger so it's like you sit back and
you're like china's building a new gps
system
to rival the us's because we have the
main gps's amused by everybody they're
going to become militaristically
independent
they're sure they're taking in more
imports than exports they're doing
beaching drills for taiwan they're
trying to seize the south china sea
they're sinking vietnamese fishing boats
they're building military bases in
violation of international conventions
and they just keep doing it what happens
if we do nothing double keep doing it
and then eventually once all our allies
are crushed and our resources are
limited then they land their boats on
our beaches and we say well the one
thing we got going for us we got a gun
behind every plate of grass yeah exactly
you know we are a nation armed to the
teeth so they will never i don't think
it's possible to conquer america no i i
just don't think it's physical like you
could literally conquer california yeah
like everywhere else it'd be really hard
no i'm i i don't i'm being facetious
it'd be difficult to take any scrapple
land on this country on this yeah yeah
like you would you would have
you you would have confederate flag
waving you know
republicans from the the you know i
don't want to say deep south but i don't
know because it's not really running
over to california the californians
you'd be like no you need to leave no
like we'd rather have the chinese here
no no no there would there would be soy
boys cowering with their you know purple
mohawk going like they're shooting at me
and it's like don't worry you're
american i may not like you at all but
we're being invaded no like you'll get
the staunchest conservatives waiting you
know confederate flags trump flags
running into battle and defending the
california soy boys
but so so there there's the really
really serious problem about war with
china it's really easy to be like i'm
anti-war exactly it is now that's easy
to say we're talking about syria in the
middle east oh i get it you want to
build an oil pipeline what did biden do
biden just approved russia to build the
pipeline anyway
so that is
let's talk conspiracies okay
i've been trying to i'm trying you guys
won't let me you want to take it i
always every single day tim
just just sends me these articles and i
have to send them to nope's faction
is that true i have brought sheamus like
15 gay frogs and he keeps telling me to
shut up
i just you don't that frog is it's
expressing itself a certain way that
doesn't have anything to do with the
chemicals in the water or anything to do
with that frog's orientation here's what
i mean i don't mean like conspiracies i
say that because
it's funny how they've turned that word
into something that means like false
stories
like like when people talk about flat
earth like it's a conspiracy theory no
no no no no if you believe in stupid
things that's just you believing in
stupid things but let me say this last
year the economy's locked down what
happened a bunch of people in our major
are our major urban hubs moved and they
moved to random places we can't like
they didn't well the half a million
people who left new york they didn't
just move from like new york to like
pittsburgh no they spread all over the
place now these are the people of means
these are heads of industry these are
wealthy individuals who command
economics who command the economy in
this country they decentralized
what else happened we realized we
couldn't manufacture things we had no
capability we tried shoring up our
manufacturing now we have a bipartisan
bill democrats republicans agree we need
250 billion dollars towards industry in
the united states
i think about these things the
decentralization of our economy the
moving out of cities i mean that's
really fortunate for us should we enter
war with china buying guns if buying
guns like firearms the riots made people
buy guns like crazy yeah if a nuke
dropped on new york last year beginning
of last year it would wipe out tons of
heads of industry it would destroy our
economy
the pandemic resulted in a
decentralization so i don't really mean
conspiracy i'm just saying how
fortuitous for us
in the event a war breaks out these
things happened
we got more people are armed to the
teeth in in cities in california
more people have left big cities and
moved out to suburbs and moved out to
rural areas and they're working remote
all these things are really good news
for our country to go to war
you know the downside of working remote
is you're you're at the whim of the
electric grid which could be a problem
if that gets knocked out but other than
that i think you're right man a big push
to get off fossil fuels you know and to
get solar energy and renewables and so
this is something i've been telling
myself maybe it's just to cope because
i'm very sad but ammo has been
ridiculously expensive for the past year
and a half and anyone who has any
interest in firearms knows that and when
i see the prices i get very sad when i
see the empty shelves i'm sad but what
that means is that more americans than
ever before have ammunition i mean the
reason the demand skyrocketed is because
everyone out went out and bought ammo
and that means the american public is
now significantly better armed than they
were prior to covet and i think that's
fantastic i was buying i think i was
buying 380 and it was like a dollar
around or something insane
i'm just i'm just
that's insane yeah i wonder what it's at
now i mean ammo isn't it i you know i've
been talking about like a good
investment and everyone's like you got
to buy this you got to buy that i'm like
you know i thought about it what i said
i've been saying for a while think about
the most common household item
that's the hardest to produce and that's
probably a good investment because in in
a when
there's like a major crisis or a war or
something
otherwise if the economy is going to
keep on keeping on the way it is without
ups and downs and you know quantitative
easing yeah well then you've got your
standard gold bitcoin whatever but i'm
talking about in the event of a war or
some kind of conflict of crisis what's a
good investment and so i think you know
like mouthwash
really really good you can use it's
antiseptic you know you can use it to
clean your mouth
really great because you don't want to
get you know infected teeth or anything
that can kill you
but more importantly like if you get a
cut
just
it's antiseptic you can use it so
alcohol works but alcohol you can't you
don't want to put in your mouth right so
hydrogen peroxide what's hard to produce
but iodine really important yeah iodine
chlorine that's been so these simple
household chemicals that we use all the
time for cleaning for for helping
ourselves those are probably good
investments but i thought about this
like
if you're going to park your money
in in anything in in in fear of some
kind of conflict what would be a good
place to do it water
yeah people need water gasoline
uh gasoline doesn't stay
yeah after a while gasoline there's
power i don't know how this would work
for a large supply but i know that there
are uh powders that you can put in
gasoline to make it last longer make it
stay longer but um uh there's other
fuels you can but i thought about i was
like you know what
gold
why why gold
we might go no no gold is good if
there's still confidence in our existing
social structure yeah if there's
actually going to be an economy to speak
up right bitcoin and gold are valuable
because of a functioning economy as it
stands today
let's say we enter uh i don't know you
know a walking dead apocalypse scenario
i do not believe that's going to happen
i know
because for the most part
it hasn't i mean countries have fallen
but they still have economies
but
i thought you were going in the zombie
direction with them for the most part it
hasn't like
no no i mean like you know
when countries and or empires fall
people still keep working and eating and
things carry on so so gold makes a lot
of sense well yeah we'll look what
happened when the ussr fell right people
still actually it was crazy people just
walked into factories took them over but
that's why i was thinking like you know
a gun really is a good investment
cars depreciate
you know a good working gun is going to
go up in value if you take good care of
it it's a decent weapon for sure yeah
yeah um i mean even um
a decent weapon i mean
if things get really bad any weapons a
good weapon you know any weapons a
decent weapon but i was i was genuinely
thinking about not the apocalypse i'm
just like what what's something you
could buy for a couple hundred bucks and
then in a few years it'll be it'll go up
in value and i'm like
guns not going to go down in value i
mean and unless they ban all guns they
won't do joe biden now he wants to do a
bunch of nfa things so they want to they
want to make um
like uh so right now if you do a pistol
with a brace joe biden was saying it's a
that's a short-barreled rifle
and i mean i've talked to a lot of gun
people were kind of like
the brace is supposed to go on your arm
but people just shoulder it which is
kind of like a stock so they want to
make that nfa which means nfa means it's
national firearms act it means you gotta
it takes a year to get it's like you
gotta go get your fingerprints you gotta
go file paperwork you gotta pay 200
bucks per item they want to make it more
difficult in that instance the guns
actually go up in value because they're
harder to get
so
it's a good investment thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast if you want to see the full
show come back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments on the show
don't forget to like share subscribe and
if you want exclusive members only
content segments you can't get anywhere
else go to timcast.com become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you